keeping it real real shall we keep it
handy daily show greetings of peace have
you seen those really big nice
billboards it says what does it say so
now look here you want to go my friend
that's what it need to say on it but it
says hey I says you suck and from actual
Muslims and you you're the the person
you're our actual Muslimin you are
actual Muslim as well so tell us about
this billboard you got out there it
actually caught some some attention of
local media and people are talking about
it well it didnt you know in last one
month it has been on to 300 media in
chicago in phoenix and st. Louis and
Miami and it CBS News covered me on
their national news you know the one of
the challenge at sound vision we have a
strategy communication center we think
of a what is the problem and how do we
handle it so question came into being is
that you know people say that why
Muslims don't condemn terrorism hey we
do it so many time it has become a sixth
pillar of Islam to condemn terrorism
five times a day and nobody is listening
neither terrorists are listening not
neighbors so that what could be the good
way of doing it so some young people
thought about this idea in Chicago they
approach that I see hey that's a great
idea and that billboard talks in the
language which people understand and
that's why media is covering it and now
our goal is to take it to time square
where 911 took place where whole world
media is based to make a point to deal
with the issue for once and for all that
Muslims are number one victims of
terrorism we hated the most much more
than you do we condemn it all the time
are you listening I'm listening loud and
clear like what you said you said that
because people who know the five pillars
of Islam one is obviously testifying
that there's nothing worthy worships at
the creator of the heavens and earth
daddy can your life to establish a
relationship with one who created you
praying five times a day but that she
said something that we're condemning
more than 50 them we're praying
condemning terrorism has become a sixth
pillar of Islam yeah we have to do it
all the time and it's still no one is
listening yeah no one is listening but
that's where Lydia comes into being and
that's where you being on air brother
oblongs is great someone you always have
haters for everything I mean with
Muslims out there doing some great
things and anybody who looked really
looks into Islam she's I salaam has
nothing to do with many of these vicious
violent acts but you know you you have
the haters some people are likewise in
this in Arabic in raka in Iraq somewhere
where they are at oh I'll give you I'll
give that hitter $2,000 go put it up
there I think they are the same people
as I say Sammy they're both hate mongers
yeah yeah I'm in the color of his skin
may be different but both are the same
with the hate humanity but you know
whether ad Muslims need to take
conversation forward it's our
responsibility as a responsible Muslims
as an excellent citizen to start a
conversation in this country that
terrorism and war is a connected
phenomena both are connected actually
there is a class value of mine Robert
Pape at the University of Chicago he has
been funded by pentagon he has complete
database of all cases of suicide bombing
and he says when drone attacks go up
suicide bombing goes up when American
troops go up in any country suicide
bombing go goes up so what he says is
the terrorism and war or a connected
phenomena there was no suicide bombing
in Pakistan Afghanistan Iraq anywhere
when did it start when bombing started
so you see we can condemn terrorism all
day long make it is six pillar of Islam
or 78 or ninth and the tenth unless our
neighbor realize what is the
contribution of war and drones and
torture in creating terrorists after
terrorists after terrorists this thing
not going to go away today it will be
named Isis tomorrow it will be some
other name and Dave
for yesterday it was al Qaeda so we need
to we have a responsibility to be a good
Muslim and a good Muslim mean that we
are a good neighbor so we can have
connection and communication with our
neighbors at the same time we are able
to be a good citizen pointing out that
how our country is hurting this is a
very important point you mentioned is
this academic Robert Robert paid yeah he
says that Islam has nothing little to
nothing to do with these terrorists not
really he says that but he also says
even Buddhism has nothing to do with
terrorists with with terrorism and he
says hindus hindus in sri lanka are the
first in the modern time who is used so
side banging against every Buddhist so
hindus against buddhist but he says
they're nothing to do with Buddhism or
Hinduism it is with the sense of
occupation or perception [ __ ]
occupation real or imagined in the case
of Iraq Afghanistan of course it's a
real occupation and in the case of
Pakistan it's a it's a it's a perception
because they are coming 40,000 feet high
you bomb people I mean I I picked you
know in Chicago now the gardens are gone
down but I love okra every time I enter
my home I go to garden first I pick
fresh okra and take it home and my wife
knows how to cook it better than me and
she fries it up and wheat it a girl in
Pakistan was in the garden picking okra
when drawn came and killed her
grandmother parents and 30 other
children she got injured also I'm a
daily life and he defected they have
this anger how they were going to
express that anger towards the united
state because united states is 40,000
feet high or its 10,000 miles away these
are the people who turn into terrorists
not all of them but some of them do so
bombing and killing them will continue
the cycle so the thing is Iraq
Afghanistan Pakistan none of those
countries have suicide bombing before
American occupation and bombing so as a
citizen we need to be confident that
speaking the truth is its duty as an
American citizen as well as a duty as a
Muslim if Muslims are not going to help
with neighbors talking on these issues
of oil swivel when it comes to Isis we
kinda mysis not only weaken demises
anytime you know that Orlando guy who
bombed and all that his mustard people
inform FBI here before that the guy is
going nuts FBI didn't do anything about
it because they were probably looking at
some laws that well he's talking about
it not doing anything but probably I
hope they had kept an eye on it on this
guy so Muslims are against terrorism
because we are the number one victim of
war as well as war of terror as well as
terrorism itself so what you're saying
is I mean these groups didn't exist you
don't have an Islamic history suicide
bombing the academic terrorist expert
said these are politically motivated so
is this the root cause of essence all
fuck-ups who's taught many people there
are many academics many people talking
about it but it doesn't that we need to
go to the root cause and this seems to
be it that the war machine is making all
these terraces in creating this boogie
man and you know like you're saying
people are sitting in there you know
small little farm or up in and at a
wedding relaxing with family reunion
next thing you know a bomb kills 50 to
100 innocent men women issue 23
generation are lost you see I'm not
saying that idea i'm not a scholar of
terrorism or walk but he is dr. Pitt he
owes her paper he's a knight well how
come they don't bring him on you don't
see him out some of these fox news
channel but now this is this is where I
say that the media it responsibility
comes in the guy cannot be more
authentic because he is funded by
Pentagon itself and he keep doing this
research and he is done amazing thing
his research is available online yeah
you can go and search the he has the
complete database of one hundred percent
of all suicide bombing in last 20 30
years Muslim Buddhist Hindu whatever you
want to call them
and he based on that research says the
suicide bombing and terrorism is a
political thing political that's
released it has nothing to do with any
religion or so nothing to do with Islam
we're going to take a break and we right
back with more with the founder of sound
vision Abdul Malik my jaw head we'll be
right back please subscribe to the dvo
follow us on our official facebook and
twitter pages in the links below please
also help support the V show by making a
donation in the link below back here on
the Dean show now that's interesting you
also helped produce this wonderful flyer
you know that's ironic because people
the haters will be out there and we
talked about this before it's like a
200-plus million dollar a year annually
it's it's a big business batching his
mom you have the Islamophobia leading at
least 2,000 to at least two hundred
million dollars that is reported to IRS
by 34 organizations there are more
organization and it doesn't include the
hate media like France all they do is
can you Tate yeah but but when you look
at for instance I mean you have the
Supreme Court you have Harvard
University honoring the comp people who
talk about Islam being unjust and the
Quran doing x y&z of injustice but
Harvard University honoring chapter 4 of
the Quran as one of the highest
expressions of Justice you also have
here the Supreme Court and tell us about
this you know honoring Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him and you guys made a
flyer about this can you tell us what is
it is it very important to realize sense
of fairness in America I mean Muslim
were not in any powerful position to
force Harvard to put a prime example of
justice to be found in Quran yeah in
which God commands you to be just even
if it goes against you individually or
against your own people similarly in
1934 Supreme Court of the United States
if you go to Supreme Court I went there
and I saw myself if you see myself as
sitting like it judges are sitting in
the Supreme Court yeah on
right hand side the second Moses first
the second comes muhammad sallallahu
wasallam as one of the greatest law
givers of the world and here are people
jumping up and down against prophet
muhammad peace be upon him so hate
mongers are not part of the America they
are hate mongers they are just like KKK
in the Christianity and now this Sam
Zion is some Christian missionaries
active jumping up and down on Islam as
Islamophobes creating a heat against
Muslims saying that we are the war
monger we are number one victims of war
more than two million Muslims have been
murdered and killed in last ten years
according to to research and one of that
research is a Nobel Peace Laureate
organization called physicians for
Social Responsibility based in
Washington DC they say just in two
countries Afghanistan and Iraq last ten
year two million people have been killed
who killed them war terrorism terrorism
kills about five ten percent of those
people rest of them were killed by war
so war and terror is connected phenomena
an additional thing is hate because
terrorists cannot kill other people
unless they generate hate similarly war
cannot kill people unless they generate
heat that's why demonization of Islam
hate towards Islam so this machine of
Islamophobia actually is a machine of
war yeah they create hate other people
bomb and murder mm-hmm so this whole
cycle of water ISM and hate must be
broken down this is powerful prices
Prophet Muhammad last and final mission
said to mankind honored by the US
Supreme Court this is like the highest
court of the land on Honor I mean these
are the mines the masterminds you know
the you know the some of the highest
people of authority they wouldn't let
this pass this is really profound this
is this is but it is important 20
Americans they can't even fathom this or
even maybe in the haters
robot they say what they did was they
were building a new building for the
supreme court in which Supreme Court
sits now took place in 30s last century
and they decided to honor 18 greatest
law givers of all times and that include
two three prophets and Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him and is one of those
Wow tell us what about we have here many
again reporters who to talk about you
know the exaggerated threat also we know
that Islam I mean this these group these
radical groups have nothing to do with
Islam you know we've been you made the
interesting point about this becoming
you know another pillar of some
condemning terrorism back and forth but
Muslims are actually suffering the worst
from many of these groups but what about
this this reporter talks about why does
why do why do they have to manufacture
its own plots if terrorism Isis Isis are
such a grave threat meaning the Z
entrapments that go on tricking muslims
you know you got these people who have
mental disorders and then they get
pulled into some kind of some kind of
plot that's mastermind you have you
heard of these events that are going on
also the manufactured terrorism but
there's a history of hyper activism by
security establishment it has happened
in the area of drugs we have the largest
number of people sitting in prison
system because three strikes and you're
out phenomena same technique of war and
terrorism sorry Warren drug is now being
applied to war on terrorism now we are
against drugs and we're against
terrorism but how do you deal with that
phenomena is something in which wiser
people need to think about for example
in the 60s and the 70s and early 80's
largest number of terrorist attack on
the United States according to FBI
statistics were coming from Latin
America Latin Americans are not Muslim
they're mostly Catholics mostly how come
that doesn't happen now Latinos from
Latin America
are not coming and hijacking our planes
they did that in the 60s in the
seventies in the 80s yeah what is the
difference at that time were sitting on
the neck we were militarily occupying or
directing or assisting dictators and
paying all the torturers in Latin
America so they hated us now still they
don't love but they are not at actually
committing a terrorism in this land so
occupation and war is connected with
terrorism phenomena now in that
environment there are some genuine
terrorists in America we have the case
of Orlando guy who's on the record and
the mosque people informed that this
guy's wet guide there was a guy in
Chicago you mentioned lower qiq person
he publicly used to talk in a mosque
about that that he wants to do this and
everybody say are you crazy you're not
supposed to do that this is not nice
then Imam sat down with him and teachers
sent down with him he was not listening
to any so for two years the guy is going
around and publicly talking about all of
those things and finally FBI entrapped
him so what's that guy bad was that guy
good no guy was low IQ he needed mental
mental services he needed some
professional guidance unfortunate nobody
provided until I FBI got him but then
there are other poor people who have
nothing to eat in Florida and FBI agent
is feeding them and talking with them
and providing them all the material and
everything say hey you want to do this
thing on bin Laden's you know take an
oath to be soldiers and all that the
guys are poor they want to eat something
or short shor shor now here they are we
you know found a terrorism case those
guys were mix of Christianity and and
some Bible reading people who didn't
know what their religion their cooking
up with ya manufactured lot of that
stuff is fixed up we condemning all of
the command nest craziness we're going
to take a break with right back with
more Hannity show please subscribe to
the dvo follow us on our official
Facebook and Twitter pages in the links
please also help support the D show by
making a donation in the link below back
here on the Dean show tell us pictures
painted of a young lady well she's going
to school where she's headed she's
minding her business god-fearing sister
and she ends up getting tackled by
several police officers Chicago Muslim
woman was running to catch her train the
next she was tackled by Chicago police
shows her in baseball cap and hijab
overtaken by five Chicago police
officers they throw me to the stick the
stairs and grab my bags they kicked me
hit me take off my head job it happened
at the loop state and lake station all
matar says police also grabbed her
backpack which was filled with food to
end her ramadan fast never telling her
why and they asked me why I put my food
inside bag why I'm Muslim why I'm
fasting why I'm running this clothes why
I cover my buddy were you afraid I'll
close to die actually she thought they
might be thieves until they arrested her
Oh matar was charged with reckless
conduct and resisting arrest today a
cook county judge found her not guilty
her attorneys say the police are guilty
of profiling and violating her rights
perhaps in the name of vigilance you
were um there at her hearing her she was
strip-searched videographed and at the
same time men were allowed to see her
naked this is the ultimate horror you
can do to a Muslim woman can you tell us
about her name what's going on with that
and paint paint the bid I paint the
right picture how did this all happen
very sad well I spent the whole day in
the whole trial it was a day long time
back up before that what actually before
it came many people don't know the story
tell us the story not this Ramadan
before last Ramadan yeah here was his
sister in downtown she covers her face
because that's how she believes in her
religion in our country gives freedom of
religion to people so whatever they
understand so she understands her
religion to be covered her face and she
is 30 year old very tiny me I'm in less
than five high
feet high and very very weak person five
officers on a train station attacked her
from the behind and throw it on the
ground and kicked her arrested her took
to thee and she was fasting and took her
duty to him you know police station
where she was stripped naked and
photographs were taken and women were
doing that but then they invited meant
to watch her also and she afraid that
those photographs were shared as well
and then finally they released her on
her on because there was nothing honor
except the charge her with resisting
arrest how in the world you so this was
last Ramadan so she was powerful enough
she went to here and there she called
care nobody responded to her she called
finally some latino friends who were not
regret who not Muslims they understand
what type of harm is done that's what
solidarity of human beings comes in and
one of the Latino activists who knew
that I support their movement and watch
with the multiple time they informed me
that Maliki nobody is supporting o
Muslim what's going on I said I didn't
know so I showed up so there were some
good attorney they fought her case they
see how in the world somebody can resist
arrest but five of you each one of you
have higher weight there she herself
twice as high air in weight and your
attack from the behind and she had no
idea you're a robber trying to snatch
her bag or what and so she got release
acquitted of all criminal charges of
resisting arrest is a joke you know
everybody's stick with this resisting
arrest thing by the police especially
when they are wrong now it's a civil
right case which going to take couple of
years before it goes to anywhere but
these type of things happen in horses I
remember that african-american girl from
Chicago who went to Texas who has failed
to put indicator to turn on the right
lane now how many times you have done
brother did that thing yesterday my wife
says hey
would be an indicator on so she was
thrown in the prison just because not
have an indicator and after three days
or two days she was found dead Wow oh
yeah a black lady in Texas so these
things police access is a real problem
weather is towards Muslims towards poor
people towards homeless white folks
towards black people towards Latinos we
need to be you know realizing that where
we call if we are attacked will Cal
Poly's right but police need to be
responsible most police is responsible
but there is no proper mechanism of
handling police which is irresponsible
and that is what is causing the problem
so that sister o is a foreign student
from Saudi Arabia who was studying here
was attacked in a month of Ramadan with
no cause whatsoever she's now acquitted
of all charges she became penniless
fighting for herself finally some public
defender turned out to be good public
defender who fought her case and Qatar
so thanks God our Texas some time
through public defender do work yeah
that's a great example because you have
a lot of police officers who do a lot of
great work but then you have you know
some some and people end up not stepping
up and taking care of these bad apples
and things get out of control and when
the good cops speak up like in New York
28 of them they were all demonized and
dismissed because they spoke up that
what is going on in New York Police
Department the New York Police
Department is so horrible people walking
on the street they will you stop them
especially the minorities Muslims and
the black they ask them to drop your
pants drop your pant to mean that you
completely naked download down there if
you don't do that you're not being the
order and resisting arrest and you'll
ridgid it simply on the street you will
be asked to drop your pants madness Wow
well our country is great country but it
got a lot of lousy stuff going on and
that's why it is important for Muslims
to work with their neighbors to make our
country better
improved better civil right better human
rights and that's why it is important to
not be alone what we work with everybody
who's being wronged to improve the
situation and the system in the process
before we conclude I want to talk just
briefly about you have another pamphlet
talks about what would the Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him because
there's so much evidence upon evidence
because if you accept that he was the
final messenger then you obviously
accept the Quran and the message of the
Quran of purpose of connection with the
Creator you know all of the wonderful
things that are there but he also he
prophesized about he warned about going
to extremes he prophesized about such
extreme groups coming I always point
this out is another evidence that he
prophesized he said that beware of such
and such groups and describing them and
we seeing these things come today so
tell us briefly what's this you have
another one what would prompt Muhammad
think of this such group because Isis is
Isis does things I mean Isis is the
reaction or to terrorism just imagine
right now two cities Aleppo Russian and
assets are bombing and then Mosul
Americans are Iraqis are bombing these
are civilians hundreds and thousands of
civilians some of them will become angry
and they're going to join Isis and Isis
will continue thrive but Isis
methodology what they are doing while
they are resisting and all that at the
same time they're violating each and
every teaching of Prophet Muhammad peace
be upon him he liberated slaves these
people insulate people yeah you have a
list here right I have a whole list of
thing and you can Harrison right here
exactly prophet says this Isis does this
prophet says this ice prophet says don't
want anything Isis bunch people to death
a prophet says that the the respect the
people of other faiths they destroy the
people of other faiths so each and
everything prophet it stood for the
people go again yeah alright we're about
out of time out of time yeah I want to
talk to you one more hour I really
enjoyed talking with you fellas are for
people that are out there and they're
tuning in you know
and you know they many people fall
victim they to this false boogie man has
been created this fear and hysteria and
people are fearing the Muslims their
fear in Islam and they tune in and what
would you what would you tell people our
friends are up or out there listening i
would say that connect with the muslim
and you will see a human being just like
you struggle just like you and when it
comes to faith there is more in common
than uncommon because God is the one who
signed all the prophets down here but
their job of the prophets was peace and
justice peace and justice Leah oh manasa
will kiss the guard says in the Quran
peace and justice and people of
different faiths need to connect in this
common struggle for peace and justice in
our homes around our neighborhoods as
well as in the world where can people
find you get in touch with you visit you
Oh people can go sound vision calm sound
vision calm one word or type actual
Muslim calm and you will land there
thank you so much always a pleasure
thank you so much variety smell and
thank you guys for tuning in we'll see
you next time every week here on the D
show follow us on the Twitter like us on
the Facebook keep up with us subscribe
if you haven't already and we'll see you
next time and until then peace be with
you sonic